uh it was always like passive learning
and reading the map correctly
uh because again there's no instructions
for how to be the best cto right there's
like the superficial things right things
need to be shipped at a great timing and
uh engineering teams should be effective
and technology should be picked in
a good way right some common sense and
some great way to trial and try us
different options
and to enable the business not for now
but for the long term right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opwest hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
meet dutan nahum ceo and founder of
spectral
dotan is an experienced
multi-disciplinary leader in tech a
four-time published author and an avid
open source contributor he is the ceo
and founder at spectral a devsecops
startup and previously was cto at hired
score clarana tlv and como conduit with
a solid background in hacking reverse
engineering and software engineering the
tan has spent years bridging the gap
between developers security and
productivity from a developer's point of
view
co-founder ceo of spectral how are you
today great how are you
good thank you so much for being here uh
i i love cyber security i love
software development i love the
integration of the two and it's such an
incredible time you know in not just the
tech ecosystem but in the israeli
ecosystem in general and i'm excited to
to pick your brain on your own journey
and and what you're doing with spectral
and how you're observing it so thank you
for being here tell me a little bit
about yourself you've done such
incredible things
throughout your career with some
incredible companies and who are you the
time
sure i don't know like it's a bit
strange uh
you know testifying uh
on yourself right so uh but
yeah i mean on on the surface i've been
uh mainly doing uh technical roles
you know in the industry like latest i
think uh 15 years
uh something like that mostly cto roles
and uh yeah in terms of my interest it
was always around empowering developers
and you know trying to build
uh
i would say developer effectiveness
tools i mean today there's so many other
names for that
it's like automation and ci cd and
all these things and uh
ied ops and
basically what i was doing throughout my
career is just you know building tools
for my fellow teammates
uh whenever i was that's that's
basically who i am yeah
now
having held
you know leadership roles whether it be
chief technology officer or lead
architect or et cetera et cetera
how you know in a few sentences how do
you perceive your
leadership in tech in your eyes
yeah actually it's uh i think leadership
in tech is very uh complex
um
there's so many books written about
being a ceo
uh right and uh so many books written
about how to be a vp sales or vp
marketing
but actually there is i think there's
just one
about how to be a cto and that one was
amazing to see uh i don't remember the
name of the author but i can send it
offline
uh i think it was out like last year
all right
and there's no like there's no actual
uh i would say career letter that is
there's no boilerplate
for someone saying i want to be a cto
one day
and kind of
telling you this is this is the these
are the milestones that you need to go
through throughout your career
and this is the the things you should
you know pay attention to right this is
how you can get there
in the base best shape that you can
right there's nothing
you mentioned the word complex and i
think that's a really good way of
describing you know tech leadership why
why is it complex in your opinion
well so so yeah i mean
so right now i'm in a ceo role so i kind
of
jump uh towards the other side kind of
being a technical ceo
but um
for me it just meant um i want when i
was a cto i really wanted to understand
all of the size of the organizations
right so when i was working
with my uh ceos
i would take extra
extra care to understand their world
right from the day to day to
goal setting to understanding their
frustrations
and
kind of being in their shoes
to be able to do my job in the best way
it was always like passive learning
and reading the map correctly
because again there's no instructions
for how to be the best cto right there's
like the superficial things right things
need to be shipped at a great timing and
uh
engineering teams should be effective
uh and technology should be picked in a
good way right some common sense and
some great way to trial and try us
different options
and to enable the business not for now
but for the long term right so many
things that you learn
on the job
and it's such a change that you have to
learn this on the job and you know by
basically failing so many times
but really there's so many so many uh
theory here
that if i would go and write a book
about it i i think i have
a full book to fill
just no time to write that book but
there's actual like lessons that are
that everyone are learning in parallel
and basically they're all the same
lessons and it's a pity that everyone
have to fail the exact same way in these
kind of roles
right i i can i can completely resonate
with what you're saying
i'll go with the same transition that
you did in your career today you're in
the chief executive role
and
which means that not just you know
looking technically but you're also
responsible for leading the company's
vision strategically financially and you
know human resources everything that
comes into play with that it's still in
a very technical field
spectral with spectral looking at you
know developers and source code and how
do you do security based on that
where did the idea for spectral come
from
yeah so uh
it's actually not an idea as much as it
was a pain
right like a growing pain and yeah
you know the
the sheer uh
the sheer uh pain of it
and if you think about it i was in cto
roles mostly leading engineers
building products
uh building new technologies
uh and this uh
obviously the security aspect was always
there
and so what i saw is that
this fantastic thing is happening where
you have really i think the last three
to four years
is the peace in history that we as
engineers
have had so many options
right so many great options
and actually i can i i kind of lived
through history long enough
to remember each and every period
uh this is by far the best
best era to live in as a developer
because you can choose your database you
can choose your programming language and
all today all program languages are
great
this is an amazing thing because mostly
throughout my career you had this one or
two programming languages that were
not good but they were working you
wanted to use and the great ones always
had disadvantages
always lack of tooling lack of
documentation lack of something and
today everything is just great i mean
you can't go wrong
and so
when you think about it
everything is just great and every
option you go for
you won't go wrong
uh in so many options
so
you know why why not use everything
right and so
when things when options
becomes vast and things kind of get
complex because now you need to learn
everything right
so let's say you want to use mongodb in
this project and then postgres on that
project maybe cockroach tb which is
completely different in other projects
but then you have the option i mean you
can move fast you can actually pick the
right technology for the problem
and then
not waste time and then just shift
things so much faster right so what's
the downside so what is the pain point
yeah what is the downside exactly right
and and this is this is a question left
unanswered
because if you you know just uh
take a view at any kind of startup
you'll see there's no downside everyone
are just picking technologies using them
shipping to production just
having a blast
how is it possible that there's no
downside
right
how is it possible so it's not possible
and what i saw is that
with all these choices comes various
types of mistakes
and they're often mistakes
and
what i was caring for is the type of
mistakes that eventually bring a company
down
so a specific set of mistakes that cause
a security breach data breach of any
kind
right uh and it can be a simple mistake
let's say we just mentioned cochran to
be i just
uh picked it off the top of my head
right
do you know how to secure it properly as
an engineer which is just playing with
it
i guess mostly no probably just yeah
you're just filling out
the system to see how you can what's the
like what is it the document db is it a
graphic b you want to find out so you
just build some project and sooner or
later you actually are finished like
this is right the product is done wow
poker gb is so great let's ship it to
production
right
and and then and then i'm saying hey did
we forget something
through this whole amazing process and
the answer is mostly yes
go back i think that when you're right
you know regarding exactly what you're
saying i'm starting to introduce but
it's interesting because you know you're
what you're talking about is
perfectly situated with the alternate
with the trend where you're mentioning
there's not it's not just that there's a
surplus of potential potential
technologies to use but but
the way that these technologies are
being brought to the world with the new
ways of documentation and the different
api systems they're actually engaging
developers to use them from day zero and
on day five already have them in
production and obviously that is also
the business model of all of all of
these softwares right the idea is that
you don't just use it as a free trial
but you take it to production and so
there's a dissonance here between the
ability for the developer and the
companies to really own what they're
doing and have full diligence on on on
the security of it
versus what they're actually doing right
and these projects are amazing i mean i
wouldn't replace i wouldn't go back in
time for for a second
i mean these options are just you know
they open up so many things
uh and so also the people who build this
project build them so well
you have documentation for everything
and it's very common to actually
uh you know trace out the section for
authentication and security and how to
bring up this database securely and so
on and so forth
but it's really uh a tragedy of
mismatched expectations like no one is i
mean you don't really realize that it is
very important
to go over the documentation for
security for this specific product right
is it your role i am just a developer
just quote
is it the devops role is it the secops
or role is it someone else down the
chain
is there actually a role for this or am
i do i actually need to take this end to
end is it all me
right
uh you know i bet
eight out of ten
companies you go and ask these questions
everyone will answer differently oh i
thought it's that person's role in this
that's what right to actually go and say
you know what this is
uh yeah this is built to uh to a
standard we've we've done
uh the risk modeling and all this boring
stuff right from a security point of
view um
i mean no one does this it's just a
bummer right because it's so so much fun
to just adopt a new new db and take it
to production
uh we need different approach
approaches for this right we need that
process it's still fun
right
and and here comes uh here comes
spectral and and the product spectrum
ops how do you make it how do you make
this fun
how do you maintain this approach but
make it accessible
so yeah so first of all it needs to be
uh i mean through your process of
experimenting let's take this this use
case right of a database whatever a new
cool database
uh there's some zen here right when
you're building you're in this you're in
the flow
you're experimenting right
um you're not going to stop open the
book and go section by section
uh and go over all these and do uh
threat modeling and right there's some
zen here
so there's need to be something that can
automate all that
and be as seamless as possible and not
interfere
and you know kind of take away all the
risk all the mistakes that you can make
right and that's basically is spectrum
so it's just a single binary it's a very
lightweight cool thing
that you install on your machine just
like docker for example just like
terraform
the vibe is the same vibe
right and and actually think about a
vibe of a tool that's also important
right of a developer what's the vibe how
does it actually look and feel what's
the ux right yeah it's a terminal thing
right it's
it's a console app it's a terminal app
but it has a ux
right
yeah just yeah and what's what is the
strategy that you're thinking towards
obviously
the goal being that at the end this is a
part of every developer's
cycle of development and and daily
workflow
what is sort of your strategy as an
early stage startup how are you getting
there so yeah so basically uh
you know there's like i think you said
it um
if you want to be the tool the developer
uses
uh
you know i first of all i think of
myself as an engineer first and as a
cyber person
very much later
although i have the background
quite a hardcore background
uh i just i kind of
put this in a very uh
very distant place
because if i think attack defense and i
go to build a tool for developer
it's not going to speak the same
language right
so
in life first i'm an engineer i like to
help engineer that's that's how i see
myself yeah there's this component of
security which i really like but i kind
of
suppress it mostly
uh
so
so then uh first of all the tool needs
to be honest
and the value needs to be immediate and
valuable
right so if you just throw some port
blah
very cryptic
and it's not immediate this is not
something that
you know is
uh a developer will want to actually fix
right now
then it's not used it's not useful
some other tool will get that the open
port some others will get that right
it's very easy to detect open ports
so what we do for example
again with a silly example of corporate
gp
we go to the documentation we open up
the configuration we understand how to
bring corporate gp in the wrong way
and then we kind of look at the
developer
facing
surface area so what are the flags here
how do i do i bring it up how do i
configure it to be production ready and
so on
and only pick these flags and let you
know about them
so hey you haven't turned on
ssl
right very basic
some products have this embedded in them
some of them some of these require some
front end to handle the ssl because ssl
encryption is kind of demanding and no
one wants to do this in process and so
on
uh
you know but there's either an approach
right so if this is a very common uh
mistake so there's one class of
forgetting not knowing about it at all i
don't know what is ssl i don't know what
is why is it useful i know that we're
regulated uh and
and why we need this as a must
maybe it's you know it's very uh it's a
very honest uh
uh
unawareness
right maybe i i build front end and now
i i'm building a full stack thing which
is a great thing because i feel very
empowered this is the right thing to do
and you know what i haven't even touched
ssl in my life right first time
or maybe this is a mismatch of
expectations so you have a load balancer
you have some f5 whatever this thing
usually does ssl termination to take off
the load of apps
uh but this time it doesn't because
someone deploys this some other way
right and now you don't have ssl so all
these small mistakes are always honest
simple naive mistakes
and this is basically what we want to
discover
while you're coding
or
actually
any way you like it you just run it as a
tool you just run it in your ide right
into your ci and this is also part of
the
of the vibe but if you have a tool for
developers are you going to dictate how
to run this tool
right must you run this in ci no this is
not how i work as a developer
first when i download something i want
to run it on my machine just to figure
out how to use it right
and then i want to kind of have it in my
id let's let's test write this right in
my id
and when i'm completely
trusting this tool
i put it in my holy place in my ci right
this is how i work as a developer and
mostly you know all developers that you
know kind of have a little sense of uh
paranoiaism or you know kind of don't
allow everything in their in their
toolbox which is
no most developers
i love it
now
where do you draw
the inspiration
so
you know it's a question that i love
asking a lot of entrepreneurs because
you know to wake up every day and to go
and and create these products and and
fight the the alcohol battle you
obviously need you know some some reason
where why you're get so excited about
what you're doing is it for you the fact
that you just spent so much time as an
engineer yourself and you saw this pain
point emerge because like you mentioned
this is not just an idea that you had
this is a pain that you've experienced
that you want to go solve
yeah i think uh like every developer
every engineer
i'm naturally lazy in a good way if
there was something already i would
actually use it
right right and the frustration is
actually
a few years building up of
uh yeah this sucks i mean
someone forgot the flag here right how
do we fix this let's uh invent some
process let's bring a pen tester that
knows about elastic right oh how do we
find this person is he really an expert
in elastic
right
you know you're always in this
vicious cycle of trying to figure out
who's the expert in this technology so
that we can bring it to production in a
great way and the answer is
ah you know new technologies have no
experts
because they're new right and today
everything is new
uh so yeah this is this is a vicious
cycle of trying to figure out like
what's the right thing to do and there's
no right answer
the time if i were to ask anybody who
worked with you previously or today
and
you know what are a few words that they
would use to describe the time
what are some things that come to mind
uh i don't know i know
i know myself i'm not sure what they
would say but uh
i can tell you that uh something that
people find strange
is that uh i kind of
self learn everything
right so
today i know how to design i know how to
do
machine learning i know how to code
and so many things that i kind of
set a target for that it's it it really
looks bizarre to people mostly so this
is the first thing that uh
become it's a little bit annoying also
because if there will be a designer i
will be i will be there to actually give
feedback and it's bizarre right
and if there's
someone building a uh an ai
solution i will be there to challenge
this uh
this feature right and it's kind of
bizarre
uh so yeah that is mostly what what what
comes off
i'll take it
on thank you very very much best of luck
with spectral amazing pain point and i
look forward to trying out the solution
myself as a coder and and best of luck
with the company and stay safe and stay
healthy perfect awesome thank you
thank you bye
you